[Musique]
bonjour les pesticides ou comment sortir
cette question qu'a longtemps été sous
la table est désormais au milieu notre
assiette
alors comment sortir par le haut en
sortir éventuellement par le bio à la
veille de la semaine sur les
alternatives aux pesticides alternative
semaine mondiale qui concerne 19 pays au
moins voici autour de cette table
etienne gangneron qui est vice président
national de la fnsea le principal
syndicat agricole
vous êtes également président de la
chambre d'agriculture du cher vous êtes
en charge du secteur bio donc au sein de
la fédé soit parce que vous êtes sur une
exploitation bio une exploitation
d'élevage dans le champagne berrichonne
dans le cher ce qui est assez rare dont
wii donc mon ma ferme se situe au nord
de bourges donc dans un système avec des
vaches allaitantes des poules pondeuses
et donc depuis maintenant un peu plus
d'un an commercialise aussi partie de
nos produits en vente directe dans un
magasin de producteurs
philippe desbrosses vous êtes alors
votre cv long comme l'histoire de
l'agriculture biologique en france parce
que internet à des pionniers depuis 1969
vous êtes installé sur la firme de vos
parents c'était amusant c'est un sologne
du loir et cher
vous avez présidé la commission
nationale de l'apel du label avait
pendant longtemps
d'ailleurs vous avez créé parmi les
créateurs de ce label ab vous êtes
expert consultant auprès de l'union
européenne vous êtes membre du comité de
veille écologique de la fondation
nicolas hulot et nicolas hulot vous le
connaissez bien parce que les fait venir
notamment aux entretiens may ans et qui
était chaque année des entretiens de
très haut niveau en plein soleil
donc ce sont des entretiens que vous
avez créés et juste avant de venir ici
et bien vous étiez en train de décharger
un camion de grain assez assez spécial
des graines de lupin c'est quoi ça ah
oui entente dans l'actualité immédiate
et bien simplement qu' on a décidé de
relancer une grande campagne pour
reconquérir notre autonomie en matière
de protéines ce qui ferait beaucoup de
bien à la france et à l'europe en
général qui dépend presque pour 5 60 70%
de ses besoins d'élevage
des importations de tourteaux de soja
pour pour pour maintenir ce modèle
ravageur d'ailleurs qui est le couple
soja maïs
donc on va essayer de réimplanter cette
plante mythique qui a qui a été la
ressource en protéines de toutes les
grandes civilisations prestigieuse avant
nous en fait c'est un vieux combat que
vous menez depuis très très longtemps et
que vous recommencez là maintenant oui
on recommence dacquois un rôle du var
vous êtes bonjour vous êtes
vice-président du conseil régionale
centre val de loire
vous êtes en charge du développement
économique est aussi d'agriculture c'est
une compétence qui n'est pas l'une des
compétences principales des concerts et
jeunes en général sauf que là vous êtes
dans la principale région agricole de
france et dont vous intervenez quels
sont les leviers d'intervention possible
pour vous mais on a un accompagnement
des filières agricoles qu'on essaie de
structurer en région et puis il ya les
aides européennes qu'ils aient ont été
longtemps géré directement par l'état et
qui sont aujourd'hui de plus en plus en
voix de régionalisation ce qui est
évidemment une bonne chose
nous allons parler plus précisément tout
au long de ce débat 82% des français
sont désormais persuadés qu'il faut
aider au développement de l'agriculture
biologique
mais pour l'instant il faut bien le dire
la france est surtout l'un des grands
utilisateurs de pesticides
c'est le troisième utilisateurs dans le
monde c'est le premier en europe voici
le tableau
dad les produits phytosanitaires sont
des composés chimiques
rassemblés sous l'appellation générique
de pesticides utilisées pour protéger
les cultures des différentes agressions
ces produits sont essentiellement de
trois types et lutte contre les
mauvaises herbes les maladies ou les
insectes
si l'on parle plus largement de
substances exogènes au sol on peut aussi
évoquer les engrais chimiques destinés à
accroître le développement des plantes
la france est un pays majeur pour
l'utilisation des pesticides numéro
trois mondial numéro un en europe la
consommation annuelle est d'environ 60
mille tonnes par an chiffre en
diminution de 30 % entre 2000 et 2010 en
centre val de loire les produits
phytosanitaires sont très présents dans
les grandes cultures
la région est la première en france pour
les traitements sur le blé dur et sur la
betterave sucrière
elle est dans le haut du tableau pour le
colza l'orge et le tournesol est
au-dessus de la moyenne nationale pour
les doses de pesticides sur les pommiers
cette pression phytosanitaire se
concentre surtout rambo ce qu'elles
soient dorées loire du loiret ou du loir
et cher mais également dans la champagne
berrichonne à cheval sur l'indre et le
cher est le résultat de tout ça et bien
que c'est que sur l'ensemble du bassin
loire bretagne
seuls 30% des cours d'eau sont en bon
état selon l'agencé de l'eau loire
bretagne et c'est la région médiane de
ce grand bassin loire-bretagne donc
c'est à dire notamment le centre val de
loire qui présentent un état détenant
dégradé je suis toujours là jean ce
secteur est caractéristique d'une
densité important de population c'est
une des causes des pollutions mais
surtout d'une agriculture et d'une
irrigation importante et pour la qualité
des eaux souterraines le constat est le
même
la contamination par les pesticides se
retrouve sur les secteurs où les
pressions d'origine agricole sont
importantes et notamment en centre val
de loire comme vous voyez sur cette
carte sur ces zones 25 polluants sont
retrouvés en quantité supérieure aux
normes dont deux plus particulièrement
ce sont deux herbicides
l'atrazine qui est pourtant interdite
depuis 15 ans et le célébrissime
glyphosate contenu dans le round up de
monsanto
d'autre part les données de la direction
generation général pardon de la
répression des fraudes tels qu'ils ont
été révélés par l'omg générations
futures données qui porte sur quatre
années de 2012 à 2016 indique que les
trois quarts des 19 catégories de fruits
qui ont été analysés sur cette période
et près de la moitié des légumes son
kata miné par des pesticides
alors on ne précise pas ça n'est pas
précisé à quel niveau auquel sont ces
molécules mais néanmoins site des
brosses peut-on s'inquiéter doit-on
s'inquiéter vous qu est par ailleurs
docteur ès environnement évidemment ce
sont ces c'est pas du tout bon pour la
santé c'est clair que tous tous et
toutes ces tous ces produits qui sont
utilisés tous ces substances qui
d'ailleurs forment un cocktail qui
augmente leur leur dangerosité
parce que on mesure pour chaque produit
une
une limite journalière en réalité on a
ce mélange qui multiplie la la la
dangerosité la danse avant leur en donne
par exemple parce qu'il ya pas que c'est
pas que le glyphosate c'est un mélange
de plusieurs molécules
oui bien sûr bien sûr et parfois une
vingtaine de molécules d'ailleurs ça se
retrouve dans les tissus des gens qui se
font ou ont fait analyser leurs cheveux
ou ya eu de nombreuses démonstrations
sur ce ça fait soixante dix ans qu'on
s'en sert et c'est vrai que ça
s'accumule en plus parce que ceux des
produits à grande rémanence donc on les
retrouve dans des cocktails explosifs
alors c'est le cas de l'atrazine
effectivement qu'on retrouve très
longtemps après un rôle du var donc
cette région elle et on l'a vu sur ses
cartes très impactées par la pollution
par les pesticides
elle et moi par d'autres pollutions les
pollutions industrielles notamment bon
voilà on n'a pas tous les malheurs en
même temps seulement l'agression
aujourd'hui c'est celle des pesticides
qu en pense ce qu'on fait régional il ya
une préoccupation qui est celle de tous
les élus c'est la dégradation des nappes
d'eau la protection des aires de captage
on est dans une situation qui est
souvent très dégradée qui est le
résultat d'une d'un modèle agricole qui
a été souvent hérités du passé où il ya
eu quand même certains excès on voit
bien d'ailleurs sur la carte que c'est
souvent les zones céréalières les
grandes cultures qui portent l'essentiel
de ces de ses séquelles et 2c de ses
traces
je préciserai rôle il va aussi la tarte
on le voit apparaître là donc on ne voit
pas effectivement l'eure-et-loir le
loir-et-cher
parce qu'effectivement elle relève du
bassin ces régions relève du bassin de
seine seine normandie mais voilà les
pollutions sont les mêmes mais les
pollutions sont les mêmes et le constat
elle même alors aujourd'hui le sujet
c'est pas deux en tout cas du côté de la
région de montrer du doigt la profession
agricole ou de mettre la pression sur
telle ou telle catégorie d'acteurs parce
que les collectivités elles mêmes sont
responsables pour une partie de la chose
l'usagé des produits phytosanitaires sur
les espaces verts
c'est terminé maintenant c'est terminé
c'est en cours on essaie d'accompagner
les collectivités pour le faire l'enjeu
aujourd'hui au niveau de la région
puisque nous on n'est pas le législateur
c'est d'accompagner la profession
agricole a évolué dans son modèle et
soutenir les forces vives de
l'agriculture les forces les plus
avancés celles qui sont le plus avancé
dans l'agro écologie dans une
utilisation raisonnée qui diminue
l'empreinte écologique puisque
l'agriculture c'est d'abord une activité
économique comme toutes les activités
économiques mais avec un fort impact sur
l'environnement qu'il faut savoir
prendre en compte vous vous êtes vous
êtes une exception je disais dans la
champagne berrichonne parce que cet
éleveur et d'autre part au sein des
faits né soit
vous êtes un peu démarqué quand même
parce que être en bio à la fnsea
jusqu'à récemment en tout cas c'était
pas vraiment la pensée dominante
je pense que c'était en lien avec les
attentes des consommateurs on a vu une
évolution quand même relativement
récente qui a permis de réassurer les
producteurs dans ce que souhaitaient les
consommateurs et c'est pour ça que
l'agriculture biologique se développe
très rapidement depuis une petite
dizaine d'années après je reviendrai
quand même une minute sur les chiffres
que vous avez évoqué parce que
j'imaginais bien que vous aviez nous
poser des questions sur sur les produits
phytosanitaires et vous avez surtout
parlé de l'atrazine donc il faut il faut
parler un petit peu technique on
retrouve aujourd'hui des métabolites
d'atrazine un produit qui n'est plus
utilisé depuis une vingtaine d'années
donc en fait on sait ce que disait a
relu var c'est l'héritage du passé
maintenant il faut se tourner vers
l'avenir il faut emmener le maximum des
régulateurs sur des étapes de transition
lors il y en a une partie qui vont aller
vers l'agriculture biologique parce
qu'aujourd'hui il ya des prix une
certaine attractivité autour des prix à
des producteurs qui qui qui retrouve de
la valeur ajoutée et du revenu mais il
ya aussi un certain nombre
d'agriculteurs qui ont besoin d'étape
intermédiaire de transition et c'est ça
qui est intéressant qui a d'ailleurs
fait l'objet tout un travail pendant le
salon de l'agriculture la suite des
états généraux de l'alimentation
contrats de solutions on est quand même
en proposer plein de choses de retourner
entre nous l'a quand même vous sortez je
crois d'un conseil d'administration dont
vous êtes toujours à psg est largement
réduit à cause de vous j'en remercie
infiniment et je veux surtout les
téléspectateurs vous en remercie au
cours de ce conseil d'admistration par
exemple est-ce qu'il était question
effectivement de l'évolution du modèle
agricole
oui on l'a évoqué sur deux deux sujets
notamment le sujet lié aux états
généraux de l'alimentation puisqu'il est
ressorti une véritable demande d'une
montée en gamme
montée en gamme des produits ce qui veut
dire plus de labels plus de bio plus de
produits sous signe de qualité mais ça
demande aussi un consentement du
consommateur puisque vous savez que dans
le même temps aujourd'hui on demande
beaucoup d'efforts aux agriculteurs mais
il ya jamais eu des revenus aussi faible
donc on a on a cette difficulté il est
beaucoup plus facile de faire engager
des gens vers de nouvelles pratiques
lorsqu'ils ont un revenu quand ils ont
l'assurance de vivre mieux de leur
métier aujourd'hui tout cela n'est pas
prouvée sauf en agriculture biologique
ou c'est vrai que ce signe de qualité a
permis depuis longtemps de maintenir des
prix relativement élevé avec la
contrepartie c'est une production plus
faible mais le contrat entre les
consommateurs et les producteurs il est
il est véritable sur l'agriculture
biologique sur toutes les autres
démarches
c'est vraiment des contrats
intermédiaires qui mérite d'être
illustrée par des prix et une vraie
réalité sur la sur le revenu des
agriculteurs
il ya eu comme un argument il est quand
même un argument qui a été beaucoup
utilisé par au moins une partie des
militants les scellés soit quand même
manifester pour cela c'est le droit ou
vif aux années spa et plus généralement
le droit d'utiliser ce que vous appelez
des produits phytosanitaires avec comme
argument il n'y a pas d'alternative
notamment sur pour le désherbage alors
que moi je vous propose de voir un
reportage d'un de vos confrères
agriculteurs bio comme comme vous deux
et ce confrère donc sept agriculteurs et
éleveurs dont les céréaliers pardon dans
le sud de la touraine voici le reportage
cela fait vingt ans que les 180 hectares
de la ferme de l'aubier abete le château
non plus reçu le moindre produit
chimique sur cette exploitation philippe
joubert et sa femme vente en direct la
plupart de leurs produits et sont variés
parce que l'agriculture biologique est
justement basée sur une rotation long
des cultures sur une même parfait entre
casey vannes 2 fait quasiment tous les
enfants le minimum c'est 15 et donc ça
reste tout ce qui
les céréales qui se font dans le
conventionnel c'est à dire du blé du
colza de
l'orge des petits pois des féveroles du
tournesol du maïs ça c'est ce qu'on
trouvait puis après nous derrière ça
c'est ce qu'on trouve aussi dans le
conventionnel et là on nous en plus on
fait du petit épeautre grand épeautre
sarrazin dulin il ya toute une toute une
panoplie du très fort en l'occurrence
qui sert de base de travail pour faire
du blé derrière mais aussi du millier du
sorgho des lentilles etc
et cette rotation des cultures permet
notamment de lutter contre l'invasion si
mauvaise herbe
le fait d'avoir des rotations longue ne
pas mettre la même culture tous les ans
un ter vers ces cultures d'hiver
cultures de printemps on casse le cycle
d'un certain nombre de mauvaises herbes
on a en ce moment dans les champs où on
est on est on a tout les toutes les
catégories de graines de mauvaises
graines qui sont dans nos de nos
parcelles
selon la méthode de culture selon les
rotations gones utilise déjà un certain
nombre qu'on va dégommer
et pour compléter cette technique
sophistiquée d'agronomie la mécanique
entre en scène
voilà le comment des racines à un
chardon et donc voit celui là il va
mourir parce que du coup on a coupé une
pièce voilà c'est un petit peu moins
efficace que le disque parce que là on
travaille plutôt pour les les plantes de
profondeur donc celle de surface on les
recouvre un petit peu moins bon par
contre celle là effectivement si on les
laisse comme ça elles vont elles vont
elles vont repartir
par contre quand on est sur un disque
c'est ce qu'on a c'est le passage qu'on
a un côté là bas ou lui ont fait un
pseudo labour donc on renferme la la
partie verte de la plante et donc melons
ce désherbage sert aussi à travailler le
sol pour préparer une culture et au
final le surplus de travail nécessaire
par rapport aux pratiques de
l'agriculture chimique n'est pas énorme
le résultat c'est pas du 100 % on a des
fois des des trucs qui repartent mais on
je dirais qu'on élimine 80% de ce qui
nous embête et donc eh ben il faut assez
accepter quand on nomme eric de logique
d'avoir un tout petit peu de mauvaises
herbes qui sont sans gravité et philippe
joubert assure la viabilité économique
de son exploitation depuis des dizaines
d'années sans polluer l'environnement ni
prendre de risque pour sa propre santé
et celle de ses consommateurs qui est
des brosses décident simplement le
retour à l'agronomie non une véritable
une bonne ce qu'on appelait une bonne
agronomie mais c'est un savoir faire qui
est sophistiqué oui sûrement pas facile
mais mais quand même très très très
logique
et si on n'avait pas sans s'était pas de
manière obsessionnelle
écarté de la bonne agronomie on aurait
pas aujourd'hui tous ces pesticides et
ses rotations qui ne correspond enfin
qui sont néfastes pour les seuls et qui
sont surtout très coûteuse pour le pour
l'agriculteur et qui là qui ensemencent
les mauvaises herbes etc
dès son retour à l'agronomie c'est par
ces pas retour au passé parce que il ya
une sophistication qui s'est faite il ya
des instituts de recherche d'ailleurs
sur l'agriculture biologique est ce
qu'il est suffisamment pourvue en
chercheur en finance il fait du très bon
travail lit table c'est vrai et puis il
ya maintenant s'appelle histoire il ya
solagro également qui fait à toulouse un
très bon travail également je voulais
simplement souligner une chose c'est que
moi je fais un parallèle entre
l'agronomie traditionnelle et
l'agronomie moderne qui qui qui s'est
efforcée
de d'éloigner toutes les fonctions
naturelles et gratuite du sol pour l'est
pour lui substituer les artifices paul
van coûteux de la pétrochimie de
l'industrie lourde et faire de nous des
otages permanente ce système le plus
évident c'est effectivement les prairies
remplacée par une alliance soja maïs
pour l'élevage alors ce qui n'était pas
le cas dans votre votre exploitation et
hayon est ce que justement en matière
d'élevage la recherche sur l'agriculture
biologique est intéressante et
suffisante alors y'a jamais suffisamment
de recherche et là je pense plus à
l'aspect recherche un peu plus
fondamentales ont parlé tout à l'heure
de semences de lupin on peut regretter
aujourd'hui que depuis trente ans il n'y
a pas eu suffisamment de recherche pour
trouver des variétés adaptées à nos
terroirs puisque sur les protéagineux
notamment que ce soit les féveroles
féveroles de printemps lupin on n'a pas
les bonnes variétés qui correspondrait à
nos climats nous soldes c'est une vraie
difficulté donc c'est facile aujourd'hui
de dire faut arrêter le soja sauf que
personne n'a vraiment travailler il va
pas personne mais il ya des gens qui ont
essayé chacun dans leur coin qui ont
fait beaucoup d'échecs
il ya beaucoup de producteurs qui ont
essayé de trouver des bonnes
combinaisons et qui ont eu des grosses
irrégularités de rendement et qui sont
revenus à des schémas beaucoup plus
classique colza blé orge qui sont
beaucoup plus régulière c'est aussi ça
l'explication
après vous l'avez montré dans le
reportage et moi je les visite cette
exploitation c'est des gens qui
travaillent très bien qu'ils ont démarré
la conversion la même année que moi par
contre
au niveau carbone il ya beaucoup
beaucoup de passages mécanique
il faut le savoir et d'une exploitation
de ce type comme la mienne sur la partie
culture l'ennemi numéro 1 c'est la
mauvaise herbe celle adventices et en
fonction des conditions climatiques des
types de sols
on a une très très grande différence
c'est à dire qu'entre la sologne de
philippe desbrosses avec des terres
facile à travailler même si elles sont
humides et les argiles que j'ai chez moi
l'argile et l'agriculture biologique ça
fait pas bon ménage
c'est très compliqué il faut faire plus
de passages doute il faut labourer
donc quand est annoncé que bien qu'en
terme de labour par rapport à la matière
organique et tous et c'est pas le
meilleur système mais on n'a rien trouvé
d'autre parce que pour compenser ce que
ce que vous utilisez ce que vous appelez
pesticides on a mis en place des
techniques mais qui sont des techniques
mécaniques qui utilise beaucoup de
beaucoup de carburant il faut le savoir
donc il ya pas de solution idéale
y'a pas solution miracle mais il ya
besoin de recherche pour accompagner
toutes ces alternatives et et en trouver
de nouvelles et moi ce que je pense et
qui a surtout un sujet qui n'a pas été
suffisamment travaillée qui est le sujet
de la combinaison des cultures c'est à
dire qu'il faut utiliser le sol au
maximum avec notamment des combinaisons
entre des céréales et des protéagineux
et ça fait vraiment des choses très
intéressantes mais là aussi il n'y a pas
eu assez de travail de recherche donc à
suivre
il ya un label en tous les cas qui
s'impose auprès des consommateurs c'est
le label ab auquel vous avez contribué
philippe desbrosses mais si la demande
explose
l'offre n'est pas n'a pas la même la
même progression et spécialement dans la
région centre
revoici un tableau dames à eux celui de
l'agriculture biologique en france et en
région centre val de loire
on l'appelle la bio pour agriculture
biologique et et la bio donc se porte de
mieux en mieux en france en 2016 ce
marché a enregistré une croissance
supérieure à 21% en surface agricole
utile cela représente un peu plus d'un
million et demi d tard soit près de 6 %
des cultures du pays c'est trois fois
plus qu'en 2007
en centre val de loire l'année 2016 est
bien plus morose la raison mais
conjoncturel la demande de conversion a
été forte en 2015 et les financements
publics n'ont pas pu suivre
résultat la région a chuté au 13e rang
français sur 14
en ce qui concerne la surface des terres
agricoles biologiques qui ne représente
que 2,3 pour cent de l'ensemble des
surfaces cultivées en centre val de
loire par département les bons élèves de
l'agriculture bio se situe dans le sud
de la région
l'indre-et-loire étant le seul à se
rapprocher de la moyenne nationale
quand le loiret et l'eure-et-loir ont de
toute évidence pris beaucoup de retard
en 2016 toutes les productions bio
régionale ont vu leurs volumes stagner
ou progressé moins vite que la courbe
nationale sauf en viticulture ou la
vigne bio bondi de 6%
deux fois plus que la croissance
française a contrario le porc bio recul
constamment depuis 2013 et a perdu plus
de 20% du troupeau régionales un échec
d'autant plus fâcheux que cette filière
estime qu'il faudrait multiplier la
production par deux pour répondre à la
forte demande des consommateurs
alors lui va si effectivement nous
sommes une région qui utilisent
énormément de pesticides par contre nous
sommes une région qui est vraiment en
queue de peloton pour le développement
de la bio c'est un constat un peu on est
une région à contretemps de la demande
des consommateurs en tout cas et
l'inquiétude des citoyens
oui mais alors l'une est une région qui
a un sujet de diversification qui est
devant nous on est une région très
marqué par les grandes cultures
c'est la base et le socle de notre
prospérité prospérité d'ailleurs qui est
plus maintenant de l'ordre du passé
voire parfois du mythe que de la réalité
vous disiez au début d'émission qu'on
est la première région région agricole
française ce n'est plus le cas
aujourd'hui à la fois en production est
alors le revenu ce qui s'effondre c'est
tout un modèle qu'il faut aujourd'hui
parce que le lien du bouchon limite du
beauceron aux poches cousues dehors même
sur des grandes exploitations et séduit
un accès moyenne neuf ou dix ans dans
notre région elle est à 300 euros par
mois de revenus selon les derniers
chiffres et on a une baisse d'année en
année depuis cinq ans qui est
continuelle est extrêmement inquiétante
sur la viabilité de tout souci c'est que
ce modèle là qu'était dominant dans la
région il est train de s'effondrer alors
justement le bio alors le bio le
problème c'est que il et il ya une
demande
elle est très forte d'ailleurs on le
voit par exemple pour le vin il ya le
vin biologique se vend sans difficulté
il ya un rythme de conversion qui est
très fort pour le reste il faut savoir
que c'est très dépendants des aides
publiques aujourd'hui pour pouvoir
passer en bio il faut avoir trois années
de revenus à peu prêt garanti pendant
lesquelles on doit produire en bio mais
on n'a pas le droit de vendre en bio
donc avec d un coût et un manque à
gagner qui est important et donc des
primes de conversion qui doivent être
assurés pour permettre de trouver le
nouveau modèle c'est ces primes-là ce
ces enveloppes là elles ont été définies
en 2014
on a eu de très très forte demande en
2015 la surface en bio elle a doublé en
2015 entre 2014 et 2015 la région sont
pas le loup dans la région de dreux les
enveloppes ont été totalement consommée
dans l'année 2016 et depuis il a fallu
dans une discussion très compliqué avec
les professionnels qui ont engagé des
politiques de conversion est derrière
qui se retrouvait avec
pas de moyens trouver des moyens
supplémentaires dans la révision à
mi-parcours de la pac la région rémi 12
millions d'euros de plus sur
l'agriculture biologique on avait trouvé
en urgence deux millions d'euros on va
dans la dans la prochaine pac dégager
aussi des moyens supplémentaires lutic
agricole commune donc ce sera politique
agricole commune
c'est une priorité est évidemment mais
il faut savoir que en région centre on
est aussi handicapé par le fait que les
enveloppes européenne des aides
européennes elles sont héritées aussi
baissé il faut préciser le schéma voilà
il ya des aides européennes via le feder
c'est ça voilà qui désormais sont
distribués par la région pour partie oui
alors c'est ça que nous parlons alors on
vous dit que vous débourser 12 millions
d'euros
donc il faut absolument et il faut il
faut savoir que quand on flèche 12
millions d'euros sur l'agriculture
biologique c'est c'est de l'argent qu'on
rajoute mais il faut savoir quand même
que globalement sur les aides
européennes
il ya d'énormes besoins et nous n'avons
plus les moyens aujourd'hui en région de
fournir tout le monde les aides
européennes des agriculteurs en région
elles ont baissé de 30 40 50% depuis
quatre ans je me suis laissé dire que
dans la région voisine grand d'aquitaine
aux nouvelles aquitaine d'ailleurs les
aides sont plus considérable alors le
maintien parce que parce qu'il faut
quand même préciser une chose c'est que
ceux qui sont en bio et qui sont
convertis déjà converti leurs terres ce
qui est votre cas depuis belle lurette
et se demande comment effectivement
s'ils vont recevoir des aides et à quel
niveau on sait plus s'il ya des ados
maintien l'agriculture bio ou pas vous
savez vous quelle est celle de la
conversion pour les 3 1 et 3 il ya les
aides au maintien
elles sont pas les payeurs sont pas
versées toujours attendre elles sont pas
versées à temps et on a ça vexe ce sujet
une discussion très compliqué avec
l'état qui assure les paiements et qui
nous garantit toujours toutes les
allures pas d'ailleurs absolument et
c'est pour moi la conviction
fondamentale qu'il faut régionaliser
l'ensemble de la politique agricole
commune et ne plus rester dans une
ambiguïté va justement un rôle du var
vous on régionalise la politique
agricole commune dont vous en avez la
charge
vous faites quoi comment vous réorienter
effectivement cette agriculture dans le
modèle dominant s'écroule et qui ne
correspond plus à demander consommateurs
alors c'est tout un chantier qu'il faut
reprendre mais il faut mettre plus sûres
l'agroécologie plus sur les stratégies
de diversification
aujourd'hui ce qui nous manque en région
c'est de prouver à la profession
agricole et à l'ensemble des acteurs y
compris les coopératives y compris la
gaule et l'industrie agroalimentaire
qu'il ya des débouchés économiques dans
la diversification et qui a un modèle
économique différent à trouver mais pour
ça il faut retrouver faut plus faut pas
discuter uniquement avec les
agriculteurs il faut retrouver la
cohérence de toute la filière amont
jusqu'à laval et les coopératives
l'industrie agroalimentaire a un rôle
considérable à jouer dans ce débat se
gagneront oui on a vraiment un enjeu de
diversification c'est à dire qu'il faut
passer à la plus de valeur ajoutée
ramener aux exploitations donc avec
l'ensemble des filières et bien
évidemment après il faut il faut
considérer qu'on a un mauvais historique
en terme de budget école régionale à
dire qu'on était avant dernière région
de france historiquement depuis 25 ans
en termes de budget alloué à
l'agriculture donc et dans les période
actuelle encore puisque les cultures où
les tout seul
est ce que c'est ça aussi mais parce que
s'achève d'ailleurs le tout seul oui
mais est-ce que c'est sûrement cette
époque là qu'il fallait engager des
filières diversifié accompagné sur
l'élevage
ce qui n'a malheureusement pas été fait
et c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui c'est
excessivement difficile de retrouver des
outils on a notamment peu de
transformations et c'est là où on peut
retrouver de la valeur ajoutée airs
diversifié c'est d'ailleurs ce qui est
intéressant dans les systèmes bio c'est
qu'en définitive on voit très bien quand
vous évoquez le fait que la région santé
en retard parce que les grands systèmes
grandes cultures c'est quand même plus
compliqué quand on passe en bio quand on
est sur un système par exemple
polyculture élevage parce que le entre
élevage et et culture on arrive à faire
des choses de l'autonomie et tout ça
fonctionne puisque les galeries l'urd à
côté du relais à niveau d'un côté ils
céréales pour nourrir les animaux de
l'autre on est on est plus autonome
voilà on baisse les charges et on arrive
à gérer son système
quand vous êtes dans un système grandes
cultures c'est assez complexe à gérer en
termes d'enherbement en termes de
technique est par contre les gens qui
réussissent bien qu'ils sont très
techniques en agriculture biologique
très vite ils vont diversifier leur
assolement en allant sur du légumes de
plein champ en allant sur des os très
très petit en effet l'avion descend
jusqu'à dix présidents des faits né sur
la vice président national de la fnsea
est ce que vous vous poussez les
connaisseurs a accepté qu'une partie des
subventions de la politique agricole
commune qui sont sauf qu'on appelle le
pilier a c'est à dire les aides directes
qui sont calculés au nombre d'hectares
historiquement est ce que vous êtes
prêts à ce que une partie de ces aides
la passe sur ce qu'on appelle le pilier
2 c'est à dire l'aide à l'aménagement
rural et notamment l'entretien des
paysages que font les agriculteurs bio
notamment mais aussi plus généralement
les éleveurs d'entre eux qu'elle l'est
etc
non mais je crois que vous posez mal la
question alors posé la bombe
l'écart est parti aujourd'hui les
agriculteurs bio ont les mêmes aides du
premier pilier qu'il que tous les autres
oui d'accord
non mais ça fait des années qu'on nous
dit des écouteurs bio moins d'être que
les autres je crois qu'il faut être un
peu sérieux à un moment donné il ya le
premier pilier de la pac qui est servi
par l'état et à le deuxième pilier qui
est maintenant gérée par la nouvelle
autorité de gestion qui est la région
sur le premier pilier
harold du var l'a dit nous avons une
baisse depuis une dizaine d'années de
plus de 40% des aides
moi je suis pas d'accord pour continuer
à assécher les aide à tous les autres
systèmes qui sont vertueux parce qu'il
ya derrière il ya des éleveurs de
chèvres de vaches laitières et tout est
pourquoi vous voudriez baisser leur aide
alors que l'état ne respecte pas ses
engagements sur les aides bio c'est là
où il faut vraiment si l'état veut un
développement de la bio on nous annonce
15%
ok moi je suis d'accord pour qu'on se
montre tel sur l'ensemble des trois donc
décidé ce t3 agriculteurs écoutez on va
se quitter sur ce consensus au mans
effectivement l'état doit assumer ses
responsabilités par rapport à la
reconversion d'un modèle nomade agricole
on va voir des brosses effectivement
moment historique est arrivé on va le
voir dans les mois qui viennent en tous
les cas je remercie d'avoir suivi cette
émission je vous souhaite une très bonne
après midi voix
[Musique]